The Medicare and
Medicaid Incentive Payments
are based on achieving the stages
of Meaningful Use, shown here.
The amount providers can earn is tied
to the number of Medicare
patients in their practice.
For the Medicaid program, 30% of
a practice is necessary to qualify,
except for pediatricians
where the threshold is 20%.
The details for
Medicare are shown here, and
you can review them
if you're interested.
Basically the earlier provider starts,
the more they can earn.
Not shown here are the reductions
in Medicare Payments for
providers that haven't achieved
meaningful use by 2015.
But there are no penalties
under the Medicaid program.
Why do you think there are no
penalties under the Medicaid Incentive
payments program?